mini gitarre gitarre riesen gitarre zwei
meter 42 groß 57 kilogramm schwer
komplett aus edelstahl und messing
gebaut hat sie martin stuttgart aus
bordesholm bei kiel und experimentell
herausfinden wieso was klingt könnte in
einer gewissen größe wie klingt ja so
eine große gitarre wie wird das vom eine
riesen gitarre will nicht mehr gepflegt
werden
sie stellt den nutzer auch vor
herausforderungen stimmen lässt sie sich
nur mit leiter und schraubenschlüssel
vier monate bauzeit stecken in dem
instrument
als erstes habe ich mir ein plan
gezeichnet
wenn dem ich mir eine gitarre nummer
papi gemessen und hab gesagt ich bau dir
eins zu 2,4 brauche ich ihnen den
größenverhältnissen später nach und dann
kam so die schwierigkeiten welche
die genehmigung für die frage wie mache
ich die seiten darauf wegen ihrer größe
müssen mindestens zwei musiker die
riesen gitarre gleichzeitig spielen
[Musik]
es macht sehr viel spaß aber auch eine
große herausforderung die wege sind weit
und es geht ganz schön auf die finger
und muss hohem druck erzeugen
aber es ist auch einfach etwas ganz
anderes auch der transport ins studio
ist bei der riesen gitarre etwas
kompliziert eigentlich baut martin
stuttgart klang kunstwerke für den
garten die riesen gitarre ist ein
einzelstück
bei der umsetzung hat er sich auch rat
bei gitarren bauern geholt
herausforderungen gab es genug etwa
schweißnähte die auf den millimeter
genau passen müssen
das war so ein glücksmoment zum gefühl
warum was hast du da gebaut das ist ja
mal richtig scharf
[Musik]
im studio kommt die riesen gitarre erst
richtig zur geltung
martin stockert digitalisiert einzelne
töne um sie später am pc bearbeiten zu
können
[Musik]
der bass die länge der schwingung wenn
wenn du die seite an spiel ist springt
durch die größe unheimlich lernen und
das gibt so ein supergeiles gefühl die
riesen gitarre von martin stock hat das
ist wirklich mal heavy metal
[Musik]